[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the boomerang of Justice now as
we were revealed just days ago the
Horowitz IG report it is now delayed two
major developments key witnesses
last-minute have now decided to
cooperate others are coming back to add
to their testimony and Christopher
Steele the one that created the dirty
Clinton bought and paid for Russian
dossier full of lies well he was grilled
by DOJ investigators for nearly 16 hours
the deep state abuse of power scandal
finally coming full circle he'll explain
more former congressman and Fox News
contributor trey Gowdy you also a
prosecutor you never lost the case I
kind of respect that about you and I
mentioned it a lot Muller has a lot of
explaining to do as Ken Starr said and
as our panel has been pointing out if
you trey gowdy were on that committee
what would you want to know more than
anything why didn't you die president
Trump was it a factual deficiency or was
it that OLC opinion that is the only
question that I think is gonna change
any dynamic coming out of that hearing
but don't we know he is why didn't you
indict the president well we know the
answer well he's he's given two
different answers I think I mean I think
he told bill war because there was a
factual deficiency but he kind of
alluded in his press conference to this
DOJ OLC opinion but didn't and if he's
gonna say that but then about five hours
later Attorney General bar and the
special counsel office released a joint
statement kind of making up for the
factual error that Muller made which was
they was talking about DOJ policy and
the constitutionality of it whether you
can or cannot indict a sitting president
write it and I think what the Democrats
going to focus on all is it had that
policy not been in place would you have
indicted private citizen Donald Trump
that's the only thing that can come out
of this for the answer how did they know
significant because of what he said to
bar it I think it has to be know for a
lot of reasons I mean I'm sorry but
firing Jim Comey is not obstruction of
justice and if it were then rod Rosen
sign would be in trouble not President
Trump but I don't that is the only quote
that that is the question that concerns
me the most if I were still a Republican
member of the house is what is going to
be his answer was it the OLC opinion or
was it a factual deficiency the rest of
it he's just gonna stick with the four
corners of his report if you're a
Republican you're gonna want to ask
about bias you're gonna want to ask
about what you didn't look into and I I
still have a bunch of friends on that
committee I would spend all of my time
getting Mulder to talk about things he
didn't bother to look for which is the
factual predicate for the Russia
investigation anything related to the
FISA process died why Kris Steele was
yeah I mean all the things that he
didn't look at he's got an out which is
I wouldn't ask to but I think it's gonna
resonate with people these are really
important issues if you have time for
medallions and taxis why didn't you have
time for this but that that's a fair
question trust me when I say this Shawn
we're not gonna learn a lot unless he
fumbles the answer from my point of view
the Republican point of view if he
fumbles the answer of why he did not
indict Donald Trump then this thing will
continue to go on for another six to
nine twelve months